s
de ses positions.
Sébastien Desrosiers. d'abord fr
Pierre Poilièvre.
- Lui-m- Lui-même est membre dui
conservateur du Canada,
il est sans doute le plus
à l'identité du nouveau chef.
ÉRIC DUHAIME, chefParti conservc
- Vous devez savoir que Pierre
c'est quelqu'un que je connais
Ç'a été quelqu'un que
j'ai rencontré à Ottawa,
on travaillait tous les deux
en politique fédérale. On était
tous les deux très jeunes.
l'époque comme un rassembleur.
Éric Duhaime veut de nouveau
collaborer avec Pierre
ouvertement sa victoire à la
prochaine élection fédérale.
- En immigration, c'est
l'attention, dans l'actuelle
campagne électorale. Plusieue. s
partis, presque tous les partis,
veulent que le Québec rapatrie
en la matière. Je pense qu'on
aurait une oreille beaucoup plus
attentive du côté conservateur
que du côté des libéraux
ou des néo-démocrates.
- J'ai jamais rencontré Monsieur
Poilièvre. Si je suis élu le 3
octobre, je vais le rencontrer.
- François Legault a également
félicité le nouveau chefade
aussi.
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe PLQ
- J'aimerais d'abord lui
réitérer qu'on a des demandes
très claires par al, notamment
sur la question du respect du
respect des champs de compétence
du Québec.
- D'autres chefs toutefois, sont
PAUL ST-PIERRE-PLAMONDON
chef du Parti québécois
- Imaginez sous un gouvernement
conservateur Poilièvre, comment
ces enjeux-là, ces intérêts-là
Les projets de pipeline, les
sables bitumineux, les cadeaux
GABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, porte-
parole de Québec solidaire
- François Legault a invité
à voter pour ce parti-là.
- Le porte-parole solidaire
s'en sert même pour attaquer
- Les membres du Parti
conservateur ont choisi
le candidat du trumpisme.
c'est un Canadien, il n'a rien
à voir avec ce qui se passe
au sud de nos frontières.ée
d'abord chez monsieur Duhaime,
particulièrement?
DOMINIQUE ROY, militante du du c
- Premièrement son charisme.
J'trouve que c'tun homme près
des gens.le parle,
qui pourrait être qualifié
de populiste, est attribué
aussi à Pierre Poilievre.
Son discours, commc Duhaime esté
sur la défense des libertés
individuelles. Si certains ont
moins d'affinité politique avec
lui, le que sa victoire permette
fouetter ses troup